alright thanks so much and it's a great
to have an opportunity to be here I've
been working with a an organization
called the Global Alliance for genomics
and health which i co-founded several
other folks and it's really about trying
to get so we can actually share large
amounts of genomic data the problem is
we are going from an era of small
studies that are funded by grant
agencies to an era where human data will
be collected on a massive scale in the
millions from clinical activities and
those data will be totally unacceptable
for research unless there's a change in
the way things are done and we're trying
to implement that change there are a
number of working groups within the
global alliance that are tackling
different issues regulatory compliance
legal and i'm working with richard
durbin on representing the data in a
format that is more amenable to the very
large scale analysis currently we're a
little bit bogged down with exchanging
these large files the BAM files and VCF
files are getting even the VC ups are
getting big and if you have a million of
these and you try to run algorithm on it
it just bogs down with IO at this point
so we need to made a new way of
representing these large databases of
genomes in a format that's more abstract
than a file format so companies like
Google or Amazon or Microsoft or alumina
can compete on the in the back end to
create these efficient databases with
API queries then you can write your code
to that API to get information out of
these databases so a little bit where
I'm coming from in the context of this
discussion we had a number of thoughts
about the human genome this is just kind
of generic background to begin with but
the obvious thing about it is we have
currently a enormous amount of human
variation but our reference genome
structure is used to for most of the
activities in other words if you can't
map
to this linear reference genome
structure a lot of stuff is getting
ignored and worse than that we have
different procedures for mapping to the
same reference genome and so results end
up being incomparable because people map
or think about mapping in different ways
so these are key problems that we have
at this point in fact because of the
complex nature of some DNA within our
genome there are estimated between 23
and 29 million nucleotides within a
typical genome that simply cannot be
mapped by most mapping procedures to the
current reference genome and there a
large number estimated about 5% of the
genome by working by eichler and others
that are in these large segmental
duplications and those are not only
variable within people but very hard to
map because you have nearly identical or
identical DNA over large stretches in
two different places within the
reference genome so this does create a
huge problem and the idea is not to keep
sweeping this under the rug essentially
like we're currently doing to think
about something that will approach this
so and and the effects we hope to have
are even even on functional transcribed
genes we have this multi mapping problem
we have some of them are broken in the
reference because it's only representing
one version which happens to be a broken
version and some are completely absent
so it's it's a mistake to think well we
don't really need to think about these
complex regions of the human genome they
do contain important important
information and we can't compete
continually ignore them more than this
as we start to understand human genetic
variation we start to look at some of
the population subpopulations of Carlos
and others have been talking about we
need to we need a way to capture that
variation as well if in the sense that
it is specific to a subpopulation what's
going on the current reference
no type is a linear the reference genome
is a linear structure fundamentally that
we use and we see in our browsers
however there's a recognition that there
is structural diversity and so we have a
proliferation over the last two
iterations of the reference genome and
you may be aware that there's a new one
that's cooking through the pipeline's
will call it HD 38 to be in sync with
NCI in ncbi at at santa cruz and it will
replace the current HD 19 verses that we
have and all of these red arrows
indicate places where there's now an
alternate haplotype or one or more
alternate haplotypes that are actually
DNA sequences that have positions within
the current HD 38 reference the problem
again being that there's no clear rule
for how one maps to one or the other and
there are cases where in fact these
things essentially overlap on their ends
purposefully to essentially anchor them
to the one path that sometimes called
the golden path from the the old days
when we did the first assembly of the
genome the reality of this is that the
structure that is actually described by
that HD 38 reference genome is a graph
not not a it's a more complicated graph
not simply a linear set of sequences and
in fact if you include the mitochondrion
we can have circular sequences as well
and so we are going to propose a
rigorous representation of a reference
genome as a sequence graph all right
sequence graph is a very very simple
object here's a description of it so
each base instance this C or this C or
any other CT or a is represented by a
structure which has the base and then
has a uuid or some stable identifier and
this is nice because when we go on to
the next version of the genome HD 39
that uuid won't change it will never
change this is the idea so we will be
adding more material possibly but never
subtracting
something away from our reference and of
course the universe of you you IDs is is
plenty so that you won't have collisions
until you have till every person has
something like millions and 600 million
you you IDs just for themselves or
something like that I think that's when
you start getting collisions under the
122 bit uuid but we don't have to go
into the details of that so we think
about this is a stable identifier and
then this little arrow here is there a
pointer or i can probably point in my
finger these little arrows are
essentially bi-directional edges because
they're not connecting the nodes but
they're connecting the sides of the node
so every base has a left side and a
right side or three prime and a Phi
prime side if you prefer and those sides
are what are adjacent to each other in
the reference genome thank you that's
great and and so each one of these edges
actually has a distinct label which is
either an outgoing arrow or an in going
arrow on each end on each incidents at
each end of that that's technically
called a by directed graph if you
consider these to be nodes it can be a
regular graph if you consider the sides
themselves to be nodes so if you look at
these graphs you can think about them as
being a generalization of a simple DNA
sequence and what's happening is that
variations form bubbles in this sequence
so here where we have a simple snip we
just have two different paths using
different nodes here different positions
will call them within the reference
structure and here when we have an
option of including or not including the
a we can skip over it and you'll see
other examples where we have much more
complicated structural variations
represented by this graph yes
royalty the fifty thousand faces yes
what do I as others we get to that yes
very good so in the compressed version
of this you might lose phasing between
them because you only have one like for
example here we lose phasing any phasing
between this variant and this variant
because we only have one set of nodes
here but if we replicated all of these
nodes between these two then we would
have a phased representation of that now
the drawback of that which would is the
body of the talks are getting right into
this is that now we have positioned we
have more and more the graph that looks
identical or very repetitive in that
sense so when we start to tease apart
things on to create phasing then we get
more repetitive structure within the
graph so will will will be talking about
how to deal with that excellent question
is it clear any other question because
this is this yes
you could you could put a probability on
it you can put various counts on it all
those would be decorations on top of the
reference genome that may become
standardized at some point but I want to
keep the reference genome definition as
simple as possible at this point so
until a community I mean that could be
community-specific annotation on top of
the reference genome if you will because
obviously any probability is going to be
population specific and you know it's
it's it gets a little more complicated
when we start to decorate this with
other information yes yes so the ID will
be universally universally different and
when we start talking about multiple
reference graphs it will be different
and then when I sequence you and I make
a graph for you you'll have completely
new set of ID so every base instance in
every genome we ever look at reference
or not has a specific uuid for it this
is the concept distinct from all other
uu IDs yes
yes right we're going to talk about that
breading but we're going to call it a
mapping from positions in your graph two
positions in the reference graph so I
wanted every position to have a uuid so
grant me that okay Carlos who uses all
right thanks okay so um yeah the one of
the issues is so how do we map so this
is the question of like so now you come
along with a variant so the reference is
a a GCT a CT blah blah blah in some
position and you are this ok and now so
some people hate gaps so they map this
with just one gap and forcing the G
enforcing this to be a kind of a crazy
match hear other people say oh well to
gaps are fine and so they're going to
map the same DNA sequence like this with
two gaps and a nice clean mapping in the
middle all right we don't want to argue
about who's right and who's wrong among
the existing methodologies we want to
come up with one methodology that
essentially maps places where there's
little or no dispute in the entire
community and we'll define a
mathematical definition of that we will
propose as a reference structure little
or no dispute and then the rest of them
will be left unmapped and what's going
to happen in the end is that most of the
stuff will map and nobody will disagree
on that and some of the stuff will have
these alternate mappings but it will be
short little pieces now and then and
you'll know that it's unmapped and you
have to think about the possible
different mappings of that so this is a
way of not dogmatically forcing every
base to map because you could have weird
[ __ ] in your genome that just shouldn't
map but trying to get a community
agreed-upon way of what should map now
where are we now we talked about human
variation with these damn VCF files I
hate VCF
I contributed to it grudgingly but it's
a horrible thing and it tries to
describe differences between your genome
or this genome sample maybe it's a
cancer sample or something and a
reference genome with various notation
and the problem is is as we added and I
must admit that our lab is responsible
for adding the general breakpoint part
to it so that we can do so that we could
do our cancer group and our cancer work
and others could do their cancer work to
analyze very complicated rearrangements
and we spent a lot of time on that but
it just proliferated this problem of
multiple ways of saying the same thing
so these three little snippets of VCF
this two-line thing being the third
expressed the same thing that there's an
a and the reference after this T and it
isn't in you right so you lost in a
somewhere ok all right if it was this
simple is fine but it turns out there's
it gets more complicated when you have
to start worrying about left shifting
and all this other stuff that people do
to try to figure out whether to VCS are
actually talking about the same variant
or a different very so we need to think
about how we can take any DNA sequence
and map it into our reference and we are
saying that in fact a property of the
reference genome should be a scheme for
mapping any DNA sequence into it and we
call that a reference structure so it's
a reference genome expressed as a grass
sequence graph plus a rule for mapping
any position in any DNA sequence into
that reference genome that should be
part of the definition of the reference
genome that we use as a standard how
would you get some of these things well
here's an example of a simple scheme
that may or may not be the one that the
community adopts but that at least it is
a definition that one could make we call
this unique context strings and it's
very simple so here is now a reference
genome that we saw before but now it's a
reference structure because in the
reference genome contain the rules for
mapping
the rules for mapping are fairly easy
they're contained in these little
strings that you see here left and right
we call those unique contexts so here's
a position P in the reference genome and
it has this left unique context a AGC so
what that is is a suffix of a path that
leads into this note here you see it
right here a AGC leads and ends in the
left side of this node so that's a
suffix of a path or thread as we call
them leading into this node p on the
left in it in fact it is the shortest
such suffix that is not similarly a
thread suffix of a thread leading into
the left side of any other node in this
graph nor is it a suffix of a path
leading into the reverse complement of
any node unfortunately DNA is
double-sided so we also have to think
about that so in particular if you look
at in the reverse complement direction
if we flip this around and think about
this node q but think about it in the
reverse complement side then we're
looking at a reverse complement prefix
coming in here and in fact this tells us
that the shorter suffix agc before T
wouldn't have worked because it's
reverse complement this is the reverse
complement a and then we have C GA so
that's match so the three base context
would not be sufficient you uniquely
identify that you're at p on the left
okay so there's always a shortest thing
that identifies uniquely where you are
or nothing so it's possible there isn't
anything that uniquely identifies where
you are in the string that you're trying
to match into this thing so this thing
this will always exist here and be
unique if the graph has some nice
properties basically there's no sub
graph automorphisms that force things to
be yeah I repeated the same chromosome
twice
there's no way I we get a unique left
context obviously right so i won't go
into that there's a nice
characterization in terms of
automorphisms and so forth that where
you were where you always have one of
these things but they're allowed to be
empty but if they're not empty then they
are the shortest thing that identifies
this position uniquely as a left context
now we can do the same thing on the
right for symmetry with prefixes and
then we have a very simple rule right so
consider so we have the shortest suffix
of a sub threatening a left side of P
that's not also on the left side of any
other node or is the prefix in the
reverse complement and we do the same
thing on the right so then we have the
shortest right prefixes and then we have
a very simple mapping rule so positions
this is an arbitrary genomes g a thread
this is a linear genome g and it's
mapping into this reference genome so a
position p will map to a position emma p
the mapping the unique mapping position
for that which can be undefined in some
cases and it does so either by being
triggered by a match on the right or
triggered by a match on the left yes
yeah extreme good change yes so we'll
we'll talk about that in a minute so the
rule is simply that if if you look at a
position P it will match so long as it
doesn't fail to match for any context on
the left and any context on the right
then it's unmapped or there's one more
case it could map to one note on the
left but a different node on the right
in that case we say it's unmapped as
well otherwise we have obviously a
unique map position and because of the
way we designed these little context
strings you can't map two places on the
left or you can and you can't map two
places on the right so either you're
mapped uniquely or you're not mapped so
very simple mapping scheme
just by exact matching and we try to
make obviously by choosing the smallest
context we try to make as much mappable
as possible we could use larger context
if we wanted to be more stringent but we
want to map as much as we can so what
happens when it's a graph your your
question this is two questions about
this so if the reference sequence is a
graph then what's going to happen for a
particular node is that you might have
multiple contexts on the left by taking
different paths into that node so what
we're going to allow in general is to
have a context set so essentially
suffixes of those paths can be chosen to
be unique among all contact sets not
also be suffixes of other contexts sets
of other nodes and those then are
triggers you want to be you don't want
any string in your context set here your
left context set here to also be a
suffix of a string in some other nodes
left context set because then you would
potentially be into a dual matching
problem so they have to be long enough
not to be suffixes of somebody else's
context set on the left side and
similarly for the right context sets and
then you simply trigger a match if you
match to anyone in the Suffolk set so
previously we only had one thing to
match to for every position in the
reference you know we had one unique
context string now we have several
unique context strings that are
sufficiently long to uniquely trigger a
match to that position and the same rule
again you can match on the left or the
right we call those a left matching or
right matching and you can see the
little that's a left matching right
matching and some of these are in both
in the sense that there's all there's
they're actually you're uniquely
identified both on the left and the
right you have the correct thing but to
the same note right otherwise you would
not be mapped so you can see in this
case again it's a little dense you can
go through this thing and see where
things map or don't map
so there there can be there's places
down here that don't map uniquely and
then there's an unambiguous places that
math either on the left or the right and
so this DNA sequence will map into this
reference structure and the reference
structure is a composite of two
haplotypes where to again apologies
we've lost phasing because we've
squashed them together yes right
excellent perfect we'll get to that
slide after this thank you so um you can
also say it to get full generality I
might want to map a sequence represented
by a graph because I did some sequencing
and i'm not sure i didn't i didn't
completely resolve your genome and i get
a graph out of it and i want to map that
grass to the reference graph and so we
then we just ask you to be able to match
every to find a unique suffix that
covers all the paths coming into you on
the Left triggering a match to a node in
the graph so we want you to match
unambiguously in that sense so we can
generalize this to graph the graph
matching which is the most general
framework for it so what about online
positions and these come about when
there's a lot of repetition in the
reference genome especially if you don't
want the context strings to be enormous
right so if I had you know very very
long identical pieces of DNA in my
reference genome i would have to the
context would have to be even longer
than that in order to be unique those
are huge context so what if you don't
want the context string no one of these
unique triggering context strings to be
longer than M basis for some reasonably
small M then what happens is you can do
merging essentially so I create a more
abstract graphs for my reference by
merging two nodes together if they have
these very long if in order to
disambiguate them I would have to have
extremely long left context then screw
it
I'm going to merge them together to be
one to be represented by one node in my
reference which is essentially kind of
what we're doing when we were doing this
merging of the haplotypes right I don't
want it I don't want to have such a long
stretch of notes to remember haplotype
phasing I'm merging them together so
that now in that structure it only
requires a small sequence but at the
same time I'm also merging these nodes
that are repetitive in the reference
structure so the reference structure
becomes more much more graphy than it
was before when we do this and if you
keep going down to this where you have
this upper limit eventually you're going
to say well if I'm in a context of one
then I have to merge and you end up with
just two nodes to non-trivial nodes this
dollar sign was a telomere symbol to
indicate the end that's not a real note
in this thing so there's the 80 note a
and it's reverse complement in the CG
node and that's all right so the whole
glass the whole graph collapses down to
essentially two nodes with a substring
and then say 15 base pairs ovation a
right so rather than rather than saying
watching between right yeah yeah so that
could avoid this that that you sure you
could still tolerate these long map
those long matching triggers without
literally having them that's true but
there's also a a reason why we the
problem is if I only have a smaller read
then I can't resolve it and I do still
want to map somewhere in the reference
genome so if I said oh no I want this
thousand base pair or 10,000 base pair
left context that region may only occur
twice in the genome and I if I have a
hundred base pair read in it I can't map
that reader because there's two
different places there's two copies of
this 10,000 base pair region but after I
collapse it I'm happy because that
hundred base read might match to
position 735 within this thing and and
that's a useful thing to me so you kind
of want to have your cake and eat it too
and I'm going to describe
to do that here so the problem with this
is that it seems like we're stuck
between an overly collapsing and an
under collapsing and we're not happy
either way so create a hierarchy there
really we try to find this right but but
they're really there really is a
fundamentally hierarchical way that we
think about these graphs so we saw an
example of a hierarchy as we collapse
more and more according to em we got
more general graphs so let's formalize
that so this is the kind of the
mathematical definition for this in
generality you have the sequence graph
and we have these notions of these
threads coming in and ending at the left
end of a node so I let's take any two
graphs G and H so we say a position P in
a graph g is less than or equal to a
position Q in a graph H if both of those
positions have the same base and every
suffix ending on the left side of P is
also a suffix ending on the left side of
Q so Q just has more suffixes than P did
on the left side and the same thing
happens with prefixes on the right and
sorry I hate DNA or the similar thing
happens with the reverse complement
right so you got to you have to throw
that in as well so it's a very natural
definition of generalization basically
you're more general that note is more
general if it has more suffixes leading
into it or prefixes on the other side
and then we can say that a graph is more
general than another graph if for every
note every position P in the graph G
there exists a unique Q in the graph H
which will denote FP with p less than or
equal to Q so that means that I can map
up to the more general graph
unambiguously that creates a hierarchy
and this is essentially what we were
dealing with so that structure turns out
to be very
very nice for mapping yes fix here 12
and so is the K varies so we could but
this is abstract and I don't think we
want to we definitely do not want to
restrict this just to k-mers or embers
so this is a very very general
mathematical construction so anyway you
want of collapsing notes or together
would create a hierarchy like this as
long as you're careful to ensure the
uniqueness of your more general node and
again that has to do with subgraph
automorphisms and so forth that I'm not
getting into at this point but it's very
easy control for that so this is now a
reference hierarchy where this would
this might be your genome with highly
resolved haplotypes and this might be
your genome with less resolved
haplotypes this might be your genome
with two separate representations of one
of edip Evan eichler's you know big
repetitive region and this might be your
genome where they're collapsed into one
part of the graph so the nice what is
the nice mathematical property of this
hierarchy as I've defined it it's
transitive mapping this is really what
you want out of this thing so again this
is the hierarchy we have the most
resolved genome down here and the most
collapse genome up here and if you have
any other graph outside of this some
other graph G that's a input graph not
in the reference and I want to map a
position p into this reference if I can
map it somewhere to a a queue in H at
some position Q in some H I then I want
to be able to say that i will also map
it to f of q in the next one HJ and
higher right so if I map somewhere in
this I want to map to the corresponding
more general note which is unique in
this hierarchy by definition all the way
up which means that everything every
position in every possible graph for
every possible human DNA experiment is
either not going to map anywhere into
hierarchy or it's going to map to a most
specific place in this hierarchy and
then automatically transitivity
transitively map everything more general
up so I only need to actually map where
it most specifically maps within this
hierarchy and everything else follows
from the function f that takes me two
more general places in the hierarchy
that has a great possibility head
there's an easy way to get it from the
left context sets and right context that
we were defining you can do that at h1
the most resolved case or in fact you
can do any mapping you want at that case
but the next one is this left context
right unique context mapping to think
about and then you simply define the
left and right context for the higher
ones by taking the union of the context
sets from the lower one and then the
cool thing you can do with that is you
can minimize them further because they
may now have redundant long suffixes but
after you collapse things you probably
don't need as much context anymore so
you can chew back the context strings as
you go up and they become shorter and
there's a unique way to do that right
you chew him back as far as you can so
that they still don't map anywhere else
very very simple intuition for that so
this is a canonical way and it tells me
in fact that we're always looking at the
at the F inverse of Q right the things
that all the things that will map up to
Q in terms of creating this Union and it
also tells me that if I'm mapping into Q
then if I want to know where I might map
to the ones below I can look at F
inverse I can go back down here and this
has the nice property that if you get
down to the bottom and you don't map
anywhere you can still get a set of
positions where you almost Matt but you
didn't have enough context it's the F
inverse thing right your context was too
short to uniquely map but there's only a
few places where you could map and so
you get a definition of multi mapping
of this in those cases which is rigorous
so there's no dispute about oh I say it
multi maps to these three places and
somebody else says no at multi maps to
these five places it only multi maps one
way in this thing if it multi maps so
uniquely maps it comes in and multi maps
and that's shown by these little little
light colored arrows in some places down
here which means it doesn't really
matter what multiplies this string the
positions in the string are going to map
somewhere now the nice part about this
graph is that it the beat collapse level
here was made from two haplotypes this
one in this one essentially by merging
and this is a result of a crossover
between these two and so it does a funny
thing when it's mapping to either of
these haplotypes by itself but it does
the natural thing after you collapse
them it just mess essentially straight
across and then as we get more abstract
assuming that we're collapsing like long
repeats within the genome at this level
then we get a more even more compressed
matching phenomenon at the top level and
we're actually proposing essentially a
three level architecture for the
reference genome as a minimal
architecture at the bottom you would be
there would be lots of actual genomes
with heavily resolved haplotypes and and
a lot of structure at the at the next
level you would you would merge
orthology positions as much as you
wanted to but resist merging paralogous
regions and then at the high level you
would go ahead and merge paralogous
regions as well and that probably would
handle most of our most of our traffic
all right so actually people before we
do this is there any are there any
questions about the idea ok so we've
started to implement this and this is
the so Benedict and my co-authors
Benedict Peyton and this is work by Adam
and prank note huff and and we have an
implementation that gums off the
Berkeley stack so Frank said in the day
Patterson lab and we have a beautiful
system that's set up for not doing large
file processing but for actually doing
computation at scale on very large data
sets May's Olson Hadoop you probably
familiar with at the low level but then
Berkeley has added spark on top of
Hadoop which is a much more flexible
kind of than your vanilla MapReduce kind
of thing in terms of parallelizing
operations and then on top of that
they've added this great package
graphics which you can imagine we're
thrilled with that because there's a ton
of graph stuff in this so to do million
note graphs or 10 million node graphs
anyone needs to have some fancy stuff
and so Adam Novak has created this
sequence graph API on top of that in
some user code and I won't go into the
details of how this is stored but the
nice part about this and it's used for
the the Berkeley read store as well the
actual DNA is stored in a columnar
format essentially so you're thinking
about everything that aligns to a
certain position being local over a
large group of genomes rather than every
genome being organized horizontally with
in the storage and this gives you a nice
architecture than for rapidly accessing
and doing a project so now when you
think about mapping a DNA sequence so
here's a DNA sequence that we're trying
to map to the reference g80 GAC and this
position G doesn't map to the reference
but these positions do map these
positions do map or do we do in fact if
this is a VCF often this stuff here is
what we call an anchor because if you
don't say anything in VCF over a long
region then it's kind of saying well I
just have the reference for this region
so we call that an anchor and there's a
huge they're huge anchors within a VCF
and then when it's get to that gets to
the VCF code like we saw before that's
trying to describe the variant that's
when things get hairy so we know where
the anchors map and using this sequence
graph package we're trying to get down
to where the variable parts map now so
between the two of them between Frank
and Adam they've got an import VCF and
an export VCF working and are in order
to test it in the current pipelines we
have to read it into the internal format
and then write the thing out again as
some kind of normalized BCF
unfortunately because nobody reads we
haven't finished the API for the direct
thing but it does this fast so even for
this 5.1 giga gigabyte VCF which is
telling you a lot about every base in
the genome essentially in this case it's
only four and a half minutes to import
and when you take this VCF you can get
away this is a reprise of this nasty
example three different ways to do it we
get away from that and we actually
decode the VCF into what string they're
actually talking about so in this case
you're talking about these strings that
get mapped canonically according to the
context rules that I just described and
you'll end these end up being mapping to
uuid 98 99 100 102 103 because remember
what this VCF was trying to say is that
typically there's an a after this T and
is not there in my genome and that ends
up being written out in a canonical way
so the bottom line is that we can do
this at scale the nice part about using
exact matching criterion is that there
are FM index suffix tree there's a whole
world of wonderful extremely fast data
structures because exact string matching
is an old and venerable part of computer
science and we have highly refined
implementations of this at this point
the FM index implementation is pre alpha
at this point but we hope
to release it and then to try this this
is actually describing an earlier run
before we had some of the things I told
you about but we tried us to do it at
scale on MHC so the last part of the
talk was describing the major histah
benefits and that ability complex now as
you know in a previous version hg19 we
had already eight different haplotypes
that are fully sequenced haploid or mono
ployed pieces of DNA for the MHC region
you can get eight more by looking at
craig Venter or other kind of celebrity
genomes and that gets to 16 high
coverage samples there's another run
that Benedict did where we were actually
including other thousand genomes data in
this as well but this was enough
variation and you can see that after you
sort out all the bases and all the
variation and so forth there's a
substantial amount that is different
between these so there's there about
five percent of the bases that are only
in one of the 16 versions of this region
that's a lot of DNA and some of that sin
genes and interesting regions and
there's almost six percent that occurs
in two of these samples but not in the
reference genome this is 18 19 or gr CH
37 so there's a lot of stuff that's not
being compared between samples because
it doesn't map to that current reference
genome and hopefully this will cease to
be a problem and then there's this nice
tool and I hope we we can get this out
there or people are starting to use it
but there's now in an assembly hub that
you can put your DNA sequences on a
bunch of related DNA sequences you can
choose one to be the reference and the
others to align to it and then you can
look at how they align with these things
called snake graphs which the red means
there's a mismatch the blue is a nice
match and then this one goes oh this
this this line says this DNA that's
mapping to this reference up here not
shown is goes over here and then goes
reverse complement and then continues
like this so it's a little inversion and
it's missing some stuff that normally
would map to the reference in its kind
of fun we call these snake diagrams
because you can see the rearrangements
cause the DNA sequence to map this
continuously in some interesting pattern
and if you look at this in a hyper
variable region all the red again shows
you the mismatch and so there is quite a
lot of structural difference and this
includes some of the short read sets
where we would map but we're missing
information so the contact ends so you
can't you don't get as much continuity
here but you still get information out
of these short shorter read context sets
so thanks so um I just have to keep my
creepy advertising a project yes I slab
funded by jim simons seems appropriate
to mention Ethel yeah we're we're doing
hygiene on coverage of 350 genomes from
many many populations yes and one of our
problems is that we're currently mapping
to coward human genome lab work yes I'm
extremely concerned about not
introducing reference part because the
whole idea is to build this data set as
a source for population and absolutely
and so you talked it mostly in your talk
you are talking about computer science
here yes but I wondered if you could
comment on what genomes you're going to
build to you to actually use for your
reference graph yeah there's something I
would love in some ideal since they got
350 genomes and build some charm graph
using your stuff I mean I thought I
would love that you I would've Eric much
love to do that yes I think this is I
think this is an incredibly important
decision and I view this is a very
important community decision where
you know working with the reference
genome consortium to actually think okay
if we if we are capable of representing
more human variation in our reference
hierarchy if you accept the idea that we
want to repre- represent more variation
than what would be our standard set for
which we would build this and it would
be great you can put your 350 at the
bottom and then merge up yes yes in our
group is interested in working I know
with you yes hyung is on the committee
that we're talking about this on of the
Global Alliance and he's giving us his
hyung feedback it was very very precise
and incisive yes so he's also interested
in trying to use these 350 kingdoms it's
yes and so if you could influence him to
okay in a big way right it's interesting
and valuable that's right I'm in
accidents they are available for
visitors we're looking for an alpha
project or maybe a beta project I think
we go we'll start with a really small
alpha project and then that would be a
beta project that would be very very
appropriate and before the larger
community will ever accept this we have
to have done some pretty thorough
implementation so if this 350 seems like
at scale real real stuff that'd be great
yes
you mentioned a little bit about the
data representation in the sort of
broader essentially the whole world
right genomic data and itching that
there would be a significant commercial
enterprise side to that which we all
know is it's / buddy now yeah and I just
but this presentation never got back to
what data structures those folks want
and where is so there's a group on the
API that's on that that's led currently
by a day Patterson here at Berkeley
actually and has participation from
Google Amazon Microsoft and increasingly
we're adding the other companies as well
as a number of labs and will grow this
to have a interest group that is
unbounded around it as soon as we can
post first standards but that the idea
of that group is to define what the API
what the data model and API operations
would look like that it is more abstract
and this is VCF or this advanced so
what's the relationship of that groups
and thicker related to this so this
which is this with this air but I mean
this doesn't look like a typical sort of
highly distributed data structure not on
this group this interfaces with that
group in a relatively small overlap
where they asked how do you how you
represent the alignment to the reference
genome so I we're proposing this as the
scheme but that group that other group
has to deal with a lot more issues than
just how to map to the rep regime which
is the sole focus of my talk today those
issues being what are the what are the
elementary API calls that you want to
make so what type of queries if we break
down what we all do into a set of
queries that form a language for
interfacing with one of these databases
what are those what's the right
factoring of this
to an API in a data model so that
standpoint what's really important is
that that API reference if this is the
next generation of a sort of creek or
optimal representation of genome yes
then it seems to me that the community
needs to really press hard that these
large enterprise investments work on
most of the sequence equal exactly yes
actually do have something more than
very expensive tags that sets right
gratuitously reference some research on
there no no that's absolutely true and
you knows exactly what we're trying to
deal with theirs is a huge proliferation
of different standards and confusion of
the back end implementation with the
actual interface and until there is a
widely accepted interface there will be
confusion in that in that regard so we
want we want to be able to have a world
in which there can be shared data sets
some of which may be in companies some
of which may be at Institute's like the
EDI and those are available through a
common API interface that one can say
okay I want to do this query or that
query on these databases because that's
what my co does and it's all code driven
retrieval of data from these databases
we have to get to that point it's not an
easy thing but if we get enough players
together to agree on an API then they
all build it back ends to that API and
might actually have exchanged ability
and compatibility yeah so this reference
genome is it made up only of celebrities
on books a movie audio recorders yeah
well you know it is these are this is
just an idea so the reference genome of
the future has yet to be built now the
referee gnome look today is still
largely based on most of it's the guy
from Buffalo who will never really know
I think it's like seventy percent the
guy from Buffalo estimate Craig winters
not Craig didn't make it no you know
the library couldn't fight through but
you know but they did what the current
reference genome consortium is working
off is not Craig it's mainly the guy
from Buffalo you have people across the
big spectrum of fitness or whatever our
diseases were you know it's just one
would want to come in fact our our
feeling about this is that we wouldn't
necessarily only start with whole
genomes at the bottom layer because DB
snip has a bunch of information that
consists of a large context on the left
then a particular point burien and then
a large context on the right well that
can be raw material at h1 the h1 level
and then it just creates a bubble when
you merge it in up there and so I don't
have to have whole genomes at the bottom
level and that's important and that will
allow us to get more variation in so I
don't think we have to decide is it
Craig in or out or is it is it just
Craig and Watson or you know who has the
star power to be in the bottom layer you
know that that should be avoidable yeah
one query you'd like to do with once you
have two individuals represented in this
way yes yes that's Rises yes yeah I
think it brings up a lot of issues there
so the fundamental thing we have here is
that you have these two individuals and
then you have the uniquely mapping parts
of them and you can go through and kind
of check check boxes that they all agree
on most of those and so that would be
the kind of boring part which the two
individuals are essentially identical
and then what your left is is little
threads of notes they tend to come in
little groups within the genomes that
don't map into the reference structure
the reference hierarchy that you have
anywhere or they not very high up so
where there's lots of blue penis and so
then you then it's a great computer
science problem house but then do the
comparison
you can essentially say okay these I
have an anchor I have an anchor it's an
overused word bank or I have a solid
mapping on the left and the right of
this little stretch of DNA into the
reference and then the same pattern
occurs over here with this other
individual solid mapping here into the
same positions of the reference and now
you're kind of narrowed it down to a
relatively short piece of DNA where
they're different and then you would
then go through a well-defined routine
for dealing with so how is that
segregating and so forth to the extent
that you had a richness in this
hierarchy of population specific stuff
you could do all kinds of interesting
analysis down there and the other thing
if it isn't obvious that i'm really
excited about with this is that it
doesn't separate out single nucleotide
variation from structural variation i'm
very frustrated with the fact that we're
almost getting two different worlds and
the fact is it's just variation people
you know it's just different DNA we
can't kind of totally separate our tools
out into one or the other all right I've
been on my soapbox